let's try instead the 972 area code
caller from 972 can you hear me what's
on your mind today hi David
this is mati calling from Jerusalem you
hear me yes I can hear you Monty thanks
great I have a quick question I heard
your interview with Josh Zepps like last
week mm-hmm yesterday and yeah and you
asked him what he thought liberals or
liberal politicians of the Democrat
Democratic Party in general should do
should be doing better and the things
that he focused on were mostly related
to the inability to point out Islamic
terrorism and the the PC stuff and when
I saw that I felt like I think I've
heard you talk about this before you
know the PC stuff it's it's a problem
granted and inability to point out
Islamic terrorism as a problem granted
but it's there seems to be so much so
many more crucial issues and to me what
you didn't talk about what I think is
important if you agree is the Democratic
Party and Democratic politicians need to
be able to package their policies and
their ideas in a way that the general
public can consume and understand that
way that it's good for them such as
universal health care ideas that
generally pull as popular but for
whatever reason there they don't seem to
be widely perceived as things that'll
ever work yeah well there's a couple
different things going on there I mean
certainly I agree with you that the
biggest problems facing the left right
now are not overbearing political
correctness and the inability or refusal
to point out when there has been Islamic
terror right I mean those are
interesting phenomena that exists in a
small sort of corner of the left I've
been critical of that period right but I
think you're completely right which is
political correctness for example is not
what is holding back the Democratic
Party Democrats Inc this corporatization
of the Democratic Party in terms of its
inability to be different than the
Republican Party on some of the major
sort of structural issues that exist and
not being left enough and I'm actually
working on a
story which is how to fix the Democratic
Party me speaking as someone who's a
progressive but has never been a
Democrat and I think that you're
generally right there it's the the major
issues political correctness is not a
voting issue for the majority of voters
nor for the majority of Democrats and
independents and I think you're
absolutely right Monty Thanks all right
no problem great to hear from you